deux all of you know qu'une cuite les
plages du maine représente pour bien des
québécois un endroit de vacances
accessibles et apprécié
il a fallu sont passées pendant deux ans
en raison de la coved mais l'attenté est
terminée et ils sont déjà nombreux à
être de retour si mon enfance c'est
comme un rituel à chaque année le petit
pèlerinage à hogan quick qui est
souligner le début de l'été l'eau est
comme à glacial
charlotte et pierre roger ne sont pas
des grands baigneurs que l'eau soit
seulement à 15 degrés ne les dérange pas
on a réservé un novembre l'année passée
quand on a vu que les douanes de
nouvelles maisons réserve ça marche pas
on en a l'eau tu peux rebondir de
retrouver
ce qu'on attendait la détente le bruit
des vagues quand on se couche le soir
la justice l'a vu
à voir les plaques je me souviens dans
le stationnement du motel qu'ils ont
réservé ils ne sont pas les seuls qui
était pressé de retrouver old shit beach
leur motel s'appelle d'ailleurs le
québec 3
selon sa gérante 80% des clients sont
québécois
à hollywood les québécois font en
quelque sorte partie de la communauté
depuis des décennies beaucoup beaucoup
de souvenirs avec les enfants même les
petits-enfants de son amour de jeunesse
même de jeunesse oui on racontera pas
ces deux dernières années le maine a
accueilli beaucoup de nouveaux touristes
américains qui découvraient leur pays
faute de pouvoir aller ailleurs mais
l'absence des québécois s'est quand même
fait sentir
le tourisme du maine avant la pandémie
en 2010 9 2 millions 300 mille canadiens
sont venus visiter le maine et ont
dépensé ici un milliard trois cents
millions de dollars bien sûr pendant la
pandémie ces chiffres ont dégringolé et
l'an dernier seulement soixante trois
mille visiteurs sont venus du canada et
ont dépensé 40 fois moins 32 millions de
dollars
ce camping de wales est resté fermé deux
ans jennyfer bachelder et son conjoint
l'ont rouvert en mai et ont vite su que
l'été serait très occupé
on a aussi rencontré reins' lafayette
qui gère trois hôtels en bord de mer
son conseil réservez vos nuits
rapidement pour un séjour cet été sting
chris
la demande est grande et les prix y ont
explosé un peu partout dans le maine
même dans les motels dit abordable une
famille de quatre qui souhaitent passer
la fin de semaine du 16 juillet à
enghien quid par exemple paiera minimum
330 $ avant taxes chaque nuit
l'inflation vient d'atteindre 8,6 pour
cent aux états unis un record en 40 ans
le prix de l'essence a beau avoir
atteint un record lui aussi aux états
unis il coûte seulement 1 $ 35 canadien
le litre ce qui compense un peu le prix
de la nourriture qui est en très forte
hausse
plus que jamais le homard devient un
luxe le l'obscurité environ 20 dollars
maintenant il est à 26 dollars ces 25 $
us la livre oui c'est une augmentation
aussi mais malgré les prix ils
semblaient tous heureux les québécois
sont de retour sur leurs bords de mer et
c'est ce qui compte le plus ici
jean-sébastien cloutier radio-canada au
goncourt